[Music]
maybe not
hey what's up my name's samuel leeds oh
hello and i
am a property developer and today you're
going to exactly see
how commercial to residential property
is done
so this is a massive commercial building
that was recently bought in a
beautiful busy street in blackpool by
two of my success students
academy members and good friends darren
and ella from dela estates
now they bought this building this whole
building for two hundred thousand pounds
they need two hundred thousand pounds to
convert it into a residential
building and break it up into apartments
and then the gross development value
is going to be between 600 and 650
000 pounds there's a lot of profit to be
made i'm going to look around right now
and see potentially
if i'd like to get in and invest on this
project too so let's look around look at
the numbers look at how it's going to be
changed and i'll tell you exactly how
this thing works let's go
so this right now is a shop now it's a
rundown shop
so this is going to stay a shop but what
we're going to do
is we're going to bore this off here
and then this area is going to become
it's a bit of a dark room at the moment
this is going to be an apartment
believe it or not it's going to be a
very spacious apartment
because we're gonna knock down
this wall right here which is literally
just a stud wall
now next door is the exact same story so
there's a big
shop so this is gonna become two shops
are going to become two slightly smaller
shops and one
big apartment so that's going to be the
first department
and the thing is at the moment
commercial properties
sometimes are cheaper than residential
properties so we want to get as much
residential space
in this building as possible in total
there's going to be six
large nice apartments i want to take you
to the next shop next door but we're
gonna have to go all the way around
because you can't get in
from the front door so let's walk around
and i'll show you what spot
[Music]
so this is shop number two and
this is all going to be part of the
downstairs apartment
all these walls are going to be knocked
down which sounds like a big job
but to be honest i could punch this
maybe not if i punched it hard enough it
would actually break i'm really
regretting doing that
so we're gonna we're gonna board this
off
and this is the second shop
now this shop it can be whatever it
wants to be so we're gonna
let the new tenant put their own stamp
on it
i'm imagining this probably used to be a
hairdresser's or a salon or something
like that
but you're probably getting rent for
these shops
you're probably talking about 650 pounds
650 pounds
rent the apartments you might get around
about four to five hundred pounds each
depending on the spec but we're going to
do them really really
nice so that's downstairs so two shops
one big apartment where all the walls
are
and it's kind of all dead space when
you've got stuff like this little
area and this little area it's just
going to be all knocked down into one
really nice
beautiful downstairs ground floor flat
i'm so excited about this project
honestly the builders say it should be
done in about three or four months so
i could literally by the end of the year
beginning of next year
this could be all done which is just
incredible so that's downstairs two
shops
one nice big apartment upstairs at the
moment there's just a whole bunch of
horrible office spaces
the walls aren't insulated properly it
is absolutely terrible
so what we're going to do is we're just
going to knock it all down knock all the
walls down start from scratch
gut it completely and put in five more
apartments at the top
that are going to be really really nice
we're going to put nice balconies
outside the front outside here
planning permissions all approved it's
all done it's all ready to go
so i'll show you exactly what's going to
happen let's go so i mentioned that
we're going to knock down all these
walls
some of them are brick walls some of
them are stud walls but you can just
tell they're not insulated but look at
this
for example i mean this is literally i
could stick my whole hand through it
so this is all gonna be knocked down
there's a lot of space so right now this
is all first
floor so if you're in america you'll
call the second floor
but in england this is on first floor so
we're one story up
and we're gonna have in total three nice
apartments
on this floor so you can literally see
it is in an absolute state
this used to be offices
it's so bad there's dead pigeons
everywhere i don't know what's worse
dead pigeons on the floor
or live pigeons or pigeon poo everywhere
but the good news is we've got all three
now this was bought i didn't buy this
this building this was bought by
a couple of my students darren and ella
from delaware estates
fabulous people they've got so much
going on this is how busy they are
they've got so many property prop
um projects going on they couldn't even
be here and also
they've got systems it's very hands-off
but i was in the area and i
am i'm trying to get in a joint venture
with darren and ella i really want a
piece of this
so i'm trying to persuade them at the
moment i i love seeing the project
the figures are juicy there's going to
be another apartment so there's an
apartment there apartment there we've
just seen and then this is going to be
apartment three and there's a lot of
space
uh emergency exit the
emergency exit which is here i'm not
gonna open this door because the stairs
are so unsafe and they're so rusty and
rattly
they're deemed not fit as a
fire escape so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna build a whole new stairs
that runs through the whole building
um which is gonna cost a little bit of
money but it's all in with the refurb
um i can't wait to see it done you
really need to in property development
you need to be able to see something
before it's done
you got to see it first and then when
you see it and you visualize it draw it
out
i've got all the plans here with me um
which darren sent me you've got to have
a good vision to draw these plans and
then once you've
seen it you see you see it first you
write it down you see it and then once
you see it and it's clear in your head
you then go make it happen
that's just the same in in real life so
far we've got two shops downstairs
everything else is going to be
residential at the moment everything's
commercial
the only thing that's going to stay
commercial the two shops ground floor
apartment
three apartments on the first floor on
the top floor
a lot of work to be done i'll take you
up there now there's going to be two
beautiful apartments
right now it's rough there's nails on
the floor it's crazy
amelia have you got the right shoes on
amelia was wearing trainers so she had
to borrow some of my shoes which were a
bit safer
let's go up another look so much pigeon
poo
oh and look two dead pigeons
okay this is gross
it's the kind of thing that puts people
off though when you've got dead pigeons
everywhere and pigeon poo everywhere
of course it doesn't actually affect the
refurb
but when people come out to view it it
just looks a bit horrible
so all this is just going to be knocked
down
completely i can even feel
the structure a little bit there has
been a structural survey done on it
which all came back okay
but there's always things with projects
like this there's all you always need a
contingency
use that's about 10 whereby if there's a
few things that aren't quite right
you've got a little bit of extra money
so what's going to happen here is
we're going to put we have to put a new
ceiling on all of this because this this
um
the roof is not too bad there's gonna be
a whole new ceiling
which you might think well that's gonna
make the room size very very small
so we're gonna lower the floor push the
floor down which won't affect the
first floor put a new ceiling on knock
the walls down
and break this down into two really nice
apartments as i said before we're gonna
put some lovely balconies on the outside
so when you're in your apartment room
you can come out step out onto the
balcony
it doesn't cost that much but it just
adds so much extra value
and it just is much better for the end
person that's going to be living here
there's two reasons that i'm really
excited
about commercial to residential
development at the moment the first
reason
is that because of the corona because of
the pandemic
a lot of businesses have been forced
to let their staff work from home more
and more companies are telling their
stuff to work from home it's being
it's becoming a thing which is meaning
that there's a lot of offices even in
london
that are empty so there's so much office
space that's empty
now how commercial properties are valued
is based on the rents
so because there's empty offices that
means if you do want to rent an office
you can get a cheaper rent
but if you've got a cheaper rent then
that means that the values dropped so
commercial properties the prices in
london and all across the uk
are dropping dramatically which is a
shame
if you're a commercial investor but
buying a cheap commercial property
and then converting it into residential
ie
apartments for people to actually live
in it's a really really smart strategy
so that's the first reason
but the second reason is because darren
and ella
had to get planning permission for this
whole project whereas
boris johnson is making it much easier
to get planning permission and permitted
development so we don't know exactly
what the changes are going to be but
it's going to become very easy to
get planning permission to convert a
commercial property into a residential
property and potentially you won't even
need to get planning permission at all
to turn shops or something above a shop
like this into a residential apartment
it's
looking like you won't even need plan
permission which is a massive
saver in time energy and resources so
this is a strategy that's very very good
right now i'm really excited
and desperately keen to see this succeed
potentially to even invest in it a
little bit and get in on it
but i think if you're going to do this
strategy it does take a lot more work
than a straightforward buy to let or
even a buy refurbished refinance there's
planning
there's the whole structural side to it
you need architects
structural engineers so you need a
really really good
team and luckily as part of the academy
darren's been able to hook into a lot of
good people
the builders working on this actually
are my students as well
they've been to the crash course which
is just amazing such a small world
unfortunately we've got a great building
team on this project
and jordan's the director so great to
have you on board jordan nice to meet
you you excited about this project i am
sure
yeah how confident are you going to get
this whole renovation done within two
hundred thousand it's
give and safe it should be it's possible
yeah yeah it is yeah what would you say
the maximum would be
i know this is always the horrible
question 220
yeah yeah so with a bit of a contingency
yeah
220 give-and-take and what are you
looking for what's your i know you've
been to the crash course
how was the crash going billions got
some good nuggets from me yeah
tall people are multi it was good yeah
and that was that must have been coming
up to a couple of years ago now 18
months ago
yeah and now you've been consistently
building your own portfolio yeah
yeah yeah obviously buy obviously buy to
let's blr deals flips
land deals whatever stacks yeah it was
until obviously the reasons
ever yeah from now just have to be a
little bit more cautious yeah
but now we're doing a lot more of the
construction and building work and then
the refred way
yeah and the crazy thing is when i was
walking to this
uh we've not met before what happened
telling the story
uh when today no just do that
yeah you look lost i was lost i was
thinking where's the problem
i was saying i'm going to a commercial
to residential you're going i'm doing a
commercial residential it actually
turned out it's the same one
and then i shake it out of the front and
then
so great really important to have a good
power team jordan it's pleasure to meet
you
too thank you so much for showing me
around you're welcome i look forward to
seeing you in 12 weeks
of course talk so get a really really
good team
jordan i'm pretty confident who's the
builder who's heading this up it's going
to do a really really good job
which means that darren and ella can
focus on other projects while this is
going on which is great
literally feels like it could fall down
on me at any moment
so i'm gonna get out of here and i'm
gonna remember
this is all about formulas not feelings
because i don't
feel that's safe right now let's go
am i going to invest in this or not it
depends on if darren and ella want me to
to be honest but i think it's a
fantastic project
and you know what most developments that
are done are done
in some form of a joint venture really
like this project
let me know what you think in the
comments below let me know if you want
to see more commercial to residential
projects as well comment below you tell
me what you want to see
i'll make it happen also please don't
forget to subscribe to the channel
smash the like button and i'll see you
next time